get the latest on the situation right
now from Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
he joins us from the State Department
mr. secretary thanks for being here
that's great to be with you the scene
heard in an interview earlier you said
that Nicolas Maduro was on his way out
or planning to leave by plane to Havana
Cuba how close did he get that's
understanding that he was ready to go he
had made a decision that we've been
urging him to make for quite some time
and then he was he was diverted from
that action by the Russians we hope we
hope he'll reconsider and get back on
that plane
we've made it very clear we support the
National Assembly their interim
president one way though and we're
supporting the Venezuelan people in
their hour where it's time to get it
right and begin to build back their
economy so that starving children can
eat and those that are sick can actually
get medicine that's sitting on the
nation's very border would he have safe
passage to Havana if you got on that
plane but we've we've made very clear
what are the expectations for materials
departure for the parsha of others - and
what our expectation is what assurances
were willing to provide them I'm not
going to discuss those here but living
is one of them but I'm just not going to
start down that path okay well what
about the Russians has there been
communication with the Russians since
they told him to stay in Caracas breath
I don't want to get into all the
conversations we had today but it's very
clear the Cubans and the Russians
understand that they are upsetting the
duly elected leader there in Venezuela
they know that I hear sometimes people
saying well the United States is
considering an invasion the invasion has
taken place the Cubans have thousands of
their officers inside of a Venezuela
today they are not there with the
consent of the government they were
there the work incentive the thug
Nicolas Maduro but not one where though
the duly elected leader of the
Venezuelan government today and for the
Russians it's the same look it's time
for Maduro to leave it's time for their
be free and fair elections and it's time
to begin to rebuild this once great
economy you know you're talking about
Cuba and Russia you have as you look at
the map here 45 nations around the world
have
recognized why though as the leader of
them as well including the US but there
are 14 countries that continue to
support Maduro Russia China Turkey Cuba
Bolivia Iran Nicaragua Uruguay Mexico
Syria Belarus South Africa Cambodia and
North Korea I mean are you turning the
screws on these countries how is that
pressure building to accept why doe so
the State Department team has been hard
at this we're now up over 50 nations I
think it's 54 or 56 nations that are
supporting one go though we're happy to
have the 57th the moment we can get it
we've made clear to the nations that you
just called out we've made clear to them
they're on the wrong side of history
that the rule of law and democracy ought
to be restored that the destruction
that's taken place over years inside of
Venezuela will be a struggle to rebuild
but it is a worthy cause and Nicolas
Maduro cannot be anywhere in the country
if the Venezuelan people hope to finally
achieve that outcome I'm confident
they'll get there and the United States
the Lima group countries in their region
their organization American states are
all supporting that you mentioned that
some in the Maduro regime talk about the
us possibly invading Venezuela one of
those was the ambassador to the UN for
Venezuela who said that the buildup in
the embassy in Bogota Colombia next door
has been to get ready for war let's
listen to this he 3000 planners 3000
intelligence officers 3,000 trainers
3,000 technicians the intelligence
information warfare technicians it's a
war embassy show me wherever in the
world there are more than 3,000
Americans in one embassy so they are
planning for war let's take off the
blindfold and look the reality as it
actually is what's your response to that
as we look at live pictures in Caracas
mr. secretary right we never talk about
the numbers we have at any particular
Embassy they change from day to day
but if the question is is the United
States prepared to consider military
action if that's what it takes to
restore the democracy there in Venezuela
president's been consistent and
unambiguous about that that the option
to use military force is available if
that's what is ultimately called for we
hope it's not
we hope there can be a peaceful
resolution and that Maduro will leave
without violence we're watching those
who are engaged in violence and we will
hold them accountable but the
president's made very very clear that we
are going to ensure that Venezuelan
democracy is restored Nicolas Maduro did
issue a tweet today and he said nerves
of steel I've spoken to all commanders
in the integral defense regions and
integral defense zones around the
country who have pledged their total
loyalty to the people the Constitution
and their fatherland are called for
maximum popular mobilization to assure
the victory of peace we will win I mean
mr. secretary that does not sound like a
guy that's getting ready to leave nerves
of steel hasn't shown himself very much
today Brett while Juan Guido is out
talking to the people of Venezuela is on
the streets shaking hands
rallying people behind him while Nicolas
Maduro has been hiding for the whole day
so much for nerves of steel as we're
continuing to look live there were you
taking by surprise that this happened on
this day and not tomorrow we've been
working to restore democracy for months
as events unfold day to day you could
never predict which day particular
events will happen on we've been we've
known that there would always be some
day that looked about like today in the
sense of the increasing opportunity for
Venezuelan democracy and we're
continuing to support that effort is
there a red line in Venezuela
if Maduro does X the u.s. does something
we've planned out lots of options we're
prepared for lots of things I don't want
to talk about what particular actions
may trigger particular responses the
president just talked about the need for
the Cubans to change their ways and what
we will do if the Cubans make a decision
to continue to engage in violence to
take down the duly elected leadership in
Venezuela but beyond that I don't want
to get into where particularly our
but the Venezuelan people should know
that not just the United States but
50-plus countries the Organization of
American States are all prepared to
continue to work and support them and
stand with them mr. secretary have two
more questions for you one is on North
Korea the North Korean saying there
needs to be a new approach to
denuclearization are you still hopeful
that that is all going to come together
seeing what you're seeing now I am I
still remain hopeful breath there's
there's only there's only one real
approach to denuclearization that's the
denuclearize right begin to take down
the threat and we're prepared to engage
in conversations to arrive at a process
by which the North Koreans can see their
way clear to fulfilling the commitment
that Chairman Kim made back in Singapore
in June of last year last thing is a
cabinet secretary would you be
questioned by staff numbers up on
Capitol Hill I haven't given it two
seconds thought it's certainly having
served in Congress for six years I don't
think it was ever the case that a
committee I was on and I was in probably
hundreds of hearings I don't think I
ever I don't think in any of the actual
committee hearings we had staff members
asking questions secretary as always
thanks for the top thank you sir